[Applaudissements]
salo qui veulent la blague a fait une
fac alors il n'y a même pas de tatamis
ges et à bruz arrêter quoi un tatami
mais vous le faites après le sol c'est
beaucoup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une fois ici on a mieux khatami on a un
tatami abonnés menace accrue le hockey
un chrono mokhtar mois du sur les prises
mais au fait du judo à la base
est ce que vous imaginez regarde qui va
s'embrouiller avec un mec il fait mais
si l'on fait du judo
[Rires]
le mec qui veut se battre et qu'il vous
voit vous faites un sport de boîte
ouais je peux me battre salut machin a
donc ne pas de salut ou pas d'accord
respectueux et impoli quand ça marche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut pas le faire ça va ça va tout à
plein temps